Buonasera.
Grazie delle belle parole.
Finalmente un altro Lorenzo in questo posto.
Dopo 500 anni.
Ci voleva. Il ricambio generazionale.
Si parla tanto di ricambio.
Allora, hanno detto che non bisogna parlare di sé a TED.
Giustamente.
Io sono un fan di TED e vi ringrazio per avermi invitato,
perché sono veramente un fan.
L'ho scoperto quando in Italia nessuno lo conosceva.
Lo facevo vedere ai miei amici.
Spesso la sera
mi metto con il computer sulle ginocchia, sul divano
a guardare gli speech perché,
a parte che si fa pratica con l'Inglese,
ma poi si fa pratica anche con l'energia, con le visioni.
Dunque, faremo un giro nelle montagne russe.
Perché 18 minuti per una canzone sono un'infinità,
ma per parlarci della vita sono veramente pochi.
Visto che appunto io so che per tradizione
a TED non bisogna parlare di sé,
inizierei con una fotografia di me da bambino.
Questo sono io.
E partirei dai desideri
che avevo negli anni '70.
Avrò avuto 10 anni più o meno, qui
e questo era il mio più grande desiderio,
era la Saltafoss, una bici da cross
che poi non sono mai riuscito a farmi regalare.
Però quello spazio che c'era tra me e la Saltafoss,
quel fosso che c'era tra me e la Saltafoss
rimane ancora la più grande fonte
di energia e anche di ottimismo, in qualche modo.
Perché c'è sempre una bicicletta da cross
che immagino aspettarmi al di là di qualche avventura.
Oggi vi parlerò di una tecnica
per rafforzare quella linea di resistenza
di cui si parlava prima,
perché l'ottimismo, se esiste,
non è semplicemente un lasciarsi andare alle cose,
ma è un lottare spesso contro le cose,
è una forma di lotta,
è una forma di impegno
perché di motivi per essere opposti all'ottimismo
ce ne sono tanti quanti sono i motivi
per essere ottimisti.
Quindi io sgombrerei subito il campo dalla parola ottimismo,
e farei largo ad un'altra parola che mi piace di più,
che è un sinonimo, per me, di ottimismo,
che è vitalità.
A me interessa la vitalità delle cose,
mi interessa la vita che c'è nelle cose,
e la promessa di vita che c'è nelle cose.
E in questo senso, la promessa di vita che c'è nelle cose
non è mai, o quasi mai, evidente al primo sguardo
e quindi il lavoro sta proprio nel cercare di individuarla.
E una delle tecniche che io utilizzo
sin da quando desideravo questa bicicletta,
io la chiamo la ricerca de "L'Effetto Bruce Lee"
Questo è Bruce Lee.
Bruce Lee è un grande eroe del cinema d'azione
di quando noi eravamo bambini.
Era un genio del Kung Fu e delle arti marziali.
Cos'è l'Effetto Bruce Lee?
L'effetto Bruce Lee è quello che si otteneva
quando si andava al cinema,
quando si era a Cortona si andava al Signorelli,
che dava i film di Bruce Lee,
a Roma c'era anche una sala parrocchiale
dove andavo a vederli i film di Bruce Lee.
L'effetto Bruce Lee è quello che si otteneva
dopo aver visto questo tipo di scena.
Io l'ho scaricata da YouTube ieri sera.
Attenzione.
Ok. Renzi hai visto?
(Applausi)
Ti consiglio dei film di Bruce Lee.
Te li presto, ho anche dei DVD.
L'effetto Bruce Lee è quello.
Che poi vai a vedere un film del genere,
da ragazzino a 7 o 8 anni, esci dal cinema
e cominci a prendere a calci i tuoi amici,
ti senti molto forte,
arrivi a casa, non so, la mamma ti dice,
"Lavati le orecchie!" e tu dici,
"A me mi dici 'Lavati le orecchie', a Bruce Lee?"
L'effetto Bruce Lee poi non svanisce,
rimane per dei giorni.
Ed è quella sensazione che ti fa essere,
ti fa camminare un po' leggero nell'esistenza,
ti dà quella spinta,
si prendono anche a calci dei lampioni
senza romperli, o degli amici.
Quindi è proprio questo effetto Bruce Lee.
Poi nella vita cambia, io adesso non è che mi carico
guardando i film di Bruce Lee;
anche se ogni tanto me li riguardo volentieri.
Perché vi parlo dell'Effetto Bruce Lee?
Perché credo che l'ottimismo, la vitalità
abbiano bisogno continuo di essere alimentate.
Non è una caratteristica
che poi rimane così immutabile, per la vita.
Per esempio,
andando indietro rispetto a Bruce Lee di una decina d'anni,
vado nel mio campo: la musica.
1958, l'Italia si ricostruisce, va verso gli anni '60,
sono anni chiave, anni in cui le cose
possono prendere una piega piuttosto che un'altra,
l'Italia in quegli anni poteva anche diventare
un paese comunista,
oppure poteva diventare qualsiasi cosa.
Erano anni chiave, chissà un po' la storia.
Io non c'ero in quegli anni.
Arriva una canzone.
(Musica)
♪ Penso che un sogno così non ritorni mai più, ♪
♪ mi dipingevo le mani e la faccia di blu. ♪
♪ Poi d'improvviso venivo dal vento rapito ♪
Guardate lui.
♪ e incominciavo a volare nel cielo infinito. ♪
♪ Volare. ♪
♪ Oh, oh. ♪
♪ Cantare ♪
Quando uscì questa canzone io non ero nato,
ma il mio babbo era nato
e i nostri genitori erano nati.
E io spesso penso a lui, in macchina,
s'era comprato con i primi stipendi
una piccola utilitaria
e aveva una radio.
La potenza di questa canzone, in quegli anni.
La potenza di un'Italia che riparte
e che per ripartire ha bisogno dell'effetto Bruce Lee,
ha bisogno di un uomo che rompe gli schemi,
che sale sul palcoscenico,
allarga semplicemente le braccia
e dice questa parola: "Volare".
Questo è quello che io intendo per Effetto Bruce Lee.
Andiamo avanti.
Motivi per alimentare questa vitalità:
la ricerca, la scienza, il progresso scientifico.
Questo è l'acceleratore di particelle del CERN di Ginevra,
quello del tunnel della Gelmini.
È l'ingresso del tunnel della Gelmini.
È bellissimo, anche esteticamente.
Le storie. La storia di Esaù e Giacobbe,
una storia che vi consiglio di andare a rileggere.
Perché non tutto va come sembra che debba andare.
Esaù in realtà è il primogenito,
però Giacobbe gli frega la primogenitura
e in qualche modo Dio premia la volontà di Giacobbe.
Perché è quello che vuole di più.
Perché lì, un conto è la legge, un conto è la volontà.
Quindi lui premia la volontà di Giacobbe
e dice no: "Esaù è il primogenito,
ma Giacobbe vuole di più questa primogenitura.
Quindi va a lui."
È una bella storia questa qua.
I viaggi: i viaggi sono importantissimi.
Io la prima cosa che dico
quando incontro dei ragazzini giovani, dico,
ragazzi, partite, partite in qualsiasi modo,
andate a vedere il mondo,
è fondamentale.
Qua ero due anni fa nel Caucaso.
Aprire gli occhi: qua ero in Iran.
In Iran mi sono accorto che sotto quei vestiti neri,
le ragazze spesso indossano queste cose qua.
È pieno di negozi nei bazar che vendono queste cose.
E insomma mi ha fatto riflettere questa cosa.
Questo è Gutenberg.
Ho fatto una ricerca in Internet
di cose che alimentano il mio senso dell'ottimismo.
Questo è un pittore che ha dipinto tutti gli Uffizi in un solo quadro.
Non è male.
L'arte.
Questo l'ho girato con il mio telefonino al Louvre.
È un'immagine che ho contemplato per la sua bellezza.
L'arte contemporanea.
Questo è Pontormo qui a Firenze,
un quadro di una bellezza incredibile,
guardate il rosa di questa pelle che bello.
Questa è arte contemporanea.
Imparare a suonare uno strumento.
Non si può fare mica solo da giovani,
si può andare avanti tutta la vita,
non è detto che poi si arrivi a suonare come lui,
ma comunque la musica è una compagna di viaggio incredibile.
Questa è una cosa che volevo fare vedere al sindaco,
ma anche a tutti voi.
A Teheran, in un parco cittadino,
c'è un busto di Dante.
La poesia. C'è un busto di Dante proprio a Teheran. La poesia è un linguaggio universale.
Leggere una poesia anche usciti dalla scuola
sembra una follia.
Invece è una cosa che io cerco di fare spesso
e a volte mi serve, mi ispira.
L'immaginazione: questa è un'immagine del 1935.
Guardate.
Dove si cominciò a pensare alla possibilità di catturare l'energia del sole.
Questa è la Bindi che fa palestra. No.
È una signora che continua ad allenarsi.
Perché l'allenamento bisogna andare avanti sempre a farlo.
L'architettura.
Ogni volta che in una città vedo delle architetture moderne
mi emoziono, perché mi danno l'idea...
pensa a un ragazzo che nasce...
Una volta un signore brasiliano mi disse una cosa molto bella.
Parlavo di architettura,
dissi, "ma non ti vergogni di vivere in una città dove ha queste..."
eravamo a Rio de Janeiro,
"...dove ha queste architetture bellissime futuristiche a pochi metri dalle favelas."
Lui mi disse, "No, perché un ragazzino delle favelas
vedendo queste architetture potrà desiderare un giorno
di andarci a vivere, lì.
Invece se non gliele fai vedere, penserà che
la sua unica condizione possibile sia quella."
E mi convinse con questa cosa.
L'architettura moderna, a suo tempo,
che era moderna allora, rimane moderna sempre.
La danza.
Vi consiglio, per alimentare la vostra vitalità,
di ballare davanti allo specchio, a casa, volume alto,
a palla; ogni tipo di danza va bene,
il tip tap, la breakdance, il liscio.
I concerti.
Io non reputo valido e utile un concerto
se uscendo non mi viene voglia di chiamare
il mio babbo per fargli un saluto, dirgli che gli voglio bene,
di pensare che il mondo sia un luogo meraviglioso.
A quello servono i concerti, a fare pubblicità alla vita, al mondo.
Quindi mi piace andare ai concerti e mi piace anche farli.
Questo è un mio concerto.
Questo è un altro modo di alzare il braccio verso il cielo.
È una ragazza araba che ha deciso
di cambiare la propria vita e di alzare la propria voce
ed è stata una reazione a catena, questa cosa.
Guardate cosa sta succedendo.
Questa è una ruota.
Penso sempre a quello che portò questa ruota
a farla vedere all'anziano della grotta.
E quello gli disse, "E che cazzo di idea è questa qua?"
Gli disse, "È pesante, che ci fai? Cos'è? Al collo, te la appendi al collo,
è pesantissima."
Lui disse, "No, secondo me ci si può fare qualcosa di utile con questa cosa."
Infatti guarda dov'è arrivato il tipo.
È partito da qui ed è arrivato qua.
Il social network.
Sono un fan dei social network.
Trovo che dimostrino l'evidenza fondamentale di oggi.
Ovvero che abbiamo più possibilità,
abbiamo più possibilità di conoscere,
nel mondo c'è più ricchezza di prima,
nel mondo ci sono più connessioni,
ci sono più speranze, non ce ne sono di meno.
Motivi per essere ottimisti.
Il corpo di una donna, l'amore, i rapporti tra le persone.
Guardate che belle queste immagini.
Questa però è la verità alla fine.
È così.
Mi piace molto quest'immagine,
perché è proprio così.
Ok. Chi è lui?
Mr Magoo. Mr Magoo.
Mr Magoo è un mio idolo.
È un mio punto di riferimento ideologico e filosofico.
Partendo da Mr Magoo, andate poi su YouTube, su Internet
a cercare perché è il mio punto di riferimento.
Passerei a un altro mio punto di riferimento,
Braccio di Ferro e Pisellino.
Lui porta a spasso Pisellino e non si accorge
che Pisellino è uscito dalla culla, dalla carrozzina,
guardate cosa fa Pisellino, si mette nei guai,
ma in realtà non si mette nei guai.
Lui non si accorge di niente.
Questo per dire che la consapevolezza è un grande valore.
Anche l'inconsapevolezza può essere altrettanto un grande valore.
Ovvero il gettarsi nelle cose
senza pensare che c'è questa cosa sopra,
qualcuno che ci controlla.
Se uno va un po' per i fatti suoi,
alla fine l'elefante magicamente può anche succedere
che non ti becca.
E se ti becca ti fa secco,
per cui non puoi neanche lamentarti.
Edoardo Sanguinetti: "...ottimismo catastrofico
che poi è la riattualizzazione in forma estrema
dell'idea gramsciana, che poi non era nemmeno di Gramsci,
era in prestito a sua volta,
o il pessimismo della ragione
che secondo me deve essere assolutamente radicale,
ma ottimismo della volontà, anzi,
quanto più la situazione è disperata,
l'ottimismo deve rinforzarsi
per cercare al possibile di rimediare
e lottare sino in fondo.
Insomma non è un eroico morire in piedi,
perché non è questo il problema,
non è individuale,
ma collaborare a riparare per quanto possibile,
per quella minima parte che ciascuno può,
la catastrofe che secondo me è piuttosto imminente."
Cercavo un supporto filosofico autorevole e anche poetico
e Sanguinetti, grande poeta mancato l'anno scorso
in questo suo discorso sull'ottimismo
mi fa pensare che non è una speranza vuota.
È vero, l'ottimismo è una forma di lotta.
L'aspettativa di vita nel mondo,
guardate un po', dall'anno zero all'anno 2000,
guardate che impennata che fa intorno al 1900.
Questi sono fatti, parliamo di cose serie.
200 000 nuove infezioni da HIV nei bambini
sono state evitate grazie alle campagne di sensibilizzazione
e alle campagne per il raggiungimento del millenium goal.
Questi sono fatti. Si dice che queste cose non servono a niente.
Non è vero, questi sono fatti, non sono chiacchiere.
L'87% delle persone nel mondo oggi
ha abbastanza cibo da mangiare
e conduce vite sane, contro il 76% del 1970.
Anche questo tutto grazie al lavoro di cooperazione,
alle donazioni, alle campagne in questo senso.
Guardate, questo rispetto al morbillo, parla di morbillo.
Grazie alle vaccinazioni
il 78% dei bambini nel mondo oggi,
in più rispetto al passato,
può evitare di prendere il morbillo.
Andiamo avanti.
Don Abbondio.
Adesso metto a confronto due figure del carattere italiano.
Don Abbondio e Pinocchio.
Don Abbondio con i bravi.
Quando incontra i bravi che fa?
Si caga sotto e ha una paura micidiale,
torna indietro,
diventa comunque uno strumento del destino
perché poi alla fine sposerà lui Renzo e Lucia,
ma da un punto di vista del percorso del personaggio
lui rimarrà immutato, nella sua vita non succede nulla.
Fa succedere delle cose, ma nella sua vita non succede nulla.
Invece Pinocchio,
quando incontra il corrispettivo dei bravi
il gatto e la volpe, si getta nelle loro mani,
si fida, gli piace questa cosa.
C'è qualcosa che gli piace.
Certo la pagherà cara.
Dovrà finire in galera, sarà costretto a fuggire,
si confronterà con il tradimento.
Passerà attraverso la forma animale, addirittura.
Si getterà nel mare in tempesta,
ma alla fine diventerà un bambino vero
e incontrerà il suo babbo,
ritroverà il suo babbo e si unirà a lui.
E questo è un altro modo di essere,
è un altro personaggio italiano.
Don Abbondio e Pinocchio.
Si può essere Don Abbondio e si può essere Pinocchio.
Io ho sempre pensato di voler essere Pinocchio.
Magari sono anche un po' Don Abbondio:
chiaramente i personaggi ce li portiamo tutti dentro.
Bene, questo l'ho trovato ieri sera in rete. Mi piaceva.
Tecnicamente il bicchiere è sempre pieno.
Questo è importante dirlo.
Inoltre ho scattato questa foto. Porco cane,
proprio mezz'ora dopo.
Quindi dobbiamo continuare a cercare,
mi dispiace ragazzi, non ce la possiamo fare.
Questo è un bel segnale che potremmo mettere
nelle porte del comune, delle scuole,
invece dell'uscita di emergenza, non è male.
Un gattino fa sempre piacere vederlo,
specialmente se mette i dischi, vero no?
La foto di un gattino alla fine funziona sempre.
Andiamo avanti, ci siamo quasi, sono quasi arrivato alla fine,
non so a che punto sono, mi sono perso.
Quanto manca? Porco cane, siamo arrivati, basta.
Ho quasi finito.
Volevo farvi sentire Rossini.
(Musica)
Questa era la musica pop dell'inizio dell'800.
"I've gotta feeling that tonight's gonna be alright."
Ho la sensazione che questa sera sarà una bella sera.
Non è una verità, ma è un modo per dirci delle cose.
Voglio salutarvi con un'ultima cosa,
con un ultimo consiglio che do prima di tutto a me stesso.
Un consiglio che, in questo stanza,
qui dette un grandissimo qualche anno fa
un mio amico, un grande, Tiziano Terzani.
Lui diceva, iniziamo la giornata con una bella risata.
Quindi oggi siamo a metà giornata,
e guardate che bella questa cosa che ho trovato in internet.
È bellissima.
Questo è un grande attore toscano,
ma in questo momento non sta recintando.
E io questo, ogni volta che c'è qualcuno triste, amico mio,
gli mando via mail questo video,
e spesso succede qualcosa.
Ve lo faccio vedere anche a voi.
Video: "...come ti chiami? E lei disse:
'Mi chiamo come il nome di un fiore.'
Disse, 'Asfodela, Tulipana...' no, no,
'Ortensia, Orchidea, Margherita, le disse tutte.
Allora disse da ultimo, non ti chiamerai mica pisciacana?'"
(Risate)
(Applausi)
(Musica)
♪ I see trees of green... red roses too ♪
♪ I see them bloom... for me and you ♪
♪ And I think to myself.... what a wonderful world. ♪
Lorenzo Jovanotti: Vi ho fatto vedere questo pezzetto di Louis Armstrong
che è nato in una famiglia poverissima
del sud dell'America,
perché nell'ottimismo in realtà c'è un seme di struggimento,
perché l'ottimismo
non vuol dire evitare il senso del tragico, ma
affrontare il tragico con un altro atteggiamento, semplicemente.
Ma il senso del tragico ce lo portiamo sempre in tasca.
O perlomeno io cerco di fare sempre così.
Per questo che ridere diventa più bello.
Credere diventa più bello.
Crederci diventa più bello.
Costruire diventa più bello.
Anche perché in fondo alla strada
c'è questa certezza che moriremo.
E questa cosa rende tutto -- non so perché,
perché qua si entra nel campo del mistero --
più interessante.
Questa è l'Onda di Hokusai,
una delle immagini più potenti del mondo.
Si parla molto di vecchi e giovani in Italia,
ricambio generazionale.
Guardate Hokusai, il grande pittore giapponese,
cosa disse a 89 anni:
"Se il cielo mi concedesse altri 5 anni,
diventerei un grande pittore."
E lui è uno dei più grandi pittori, guardate quest'immagine,
stampata su miliardi di magliette.
Vi lascio con un'altra frase, e poi vi saluto.
"Ho impiegato 4 anni per imparare a dipingere come Raffaello
e tutta una vita per riuscire a dipingere come un bambino."
Picasso.
(Applausi)
Manca una sola foto.
Manca una sola foto, che per me però è la più importante,
in questa sala, di fronte a voi,
di fronte al futuro che ci aspetta
e con il passato che abbiamo alle spalle.
È questa.
Il primo articolo della nostra costituzione.
"L'Italia è una repubblica democratica fondata sul lavoro."
Senza il lavoro non ci può essere ottimismo,
non ci può essere innovazione,
non ci può essere niente.
Per cui l'unica vera cosa che chiediamo alla politica--
c'è qui il sindaco Renzi che ha, giustamente,
grandi sogni e grande voglia di impegnarsi --
il punto è il lavoro.
Il punto è il lavoro.
Io ho sempre pensato al lavoro
non come a qualcosa che ti viene dato,
ma come qualcosa che dai.
Non come un'opportunità che ti viene offerta,
ma come un'opportunità che ti cerchi.
Come una strada che ti costruisci.
Chiaramente queste due cose si devono incontrare a metà.
Il punto chiave del nostro paese in questo momento
rimane questo.
Se noi riusciamo a discutere su questo punto
e a capire dove andare rispetto a questo tema,
abbiamo risolto una bella parte di tutti i nostri problemi.
Grazie a tutti. Grazie a TED. Buona fortuna.
(Applausi)
Grazie.